de l'autre côté de la mer d'étoiles se trouve un autre
monde un monde presque exactement comme le
nôtre c'est là qu'il vit il a 27 ans
célibataire mais à la recherche de sports préférés
planche à voile
et Aïkido passe-temps favoris cigares et
sexe il a tout sauf l'épanouissement
et puis une nuit il arrive qu'il a un
crise de la quarantaine très soudaine il atterrit à
Cleveland tu sais pourquoi tu m'as été envoyé
écoute moi petit visiteur je peux
expliquer comment tu es arrivé ici peut-être qu'ici
n'était pas un plus grand but une cause cosmique
ici il est obligé de réévaluer ses
objectifs de carrière toi avec le med  l'école pour explorer de
nouvelles relations pour redéfinir son
image de soi Je suis désolé, nous n'autorisons pas les animaux
de compagnie sur les lieux à s'adapter à un
mode de vie changeant jusqu'à ce qu'il
découvre qui il est vraiment
oh tu es un canard dans  gros problème
c'est un canard Howard le canard
piégé dans un monde qu'il n'a jamais fait venant
de George Lucas un film de Willard Huyck une
production de Gloria Katz